numbers are tricky and they're even
trickier in politics some numbers are
valid and support my arguments well
others are backstabbing fakes that go
against my argument those numbers are
called lies now this is complicated even
the same numbers can change allegiance
like the unemployment numbers earlier
this year you remember when they were
fake and then they became real when
Trump took over the President is
referred to particulars reports as phony
or totally fiction because the president
believed that this jobs report was
accurate and a fair way way to measure
the government yeah I talked to the
president prior to this and he said to
quote him very clearly they may have
been phony in the past but it's very
real now they're laughing at how
ridiculous they sound asking that
question in the first place
so let's find out if this week's numbers
are good guys or bad guys
first up Trump's latest approval numbers
the numbers are looking a bit better for
President Trump he's at 43% in our new
NBC news/wall Street Journal poll that's
a three point uptick since August is
also up in Gallup so this is across the
board
okay 43 you've seemed innocent enough
but uh what do we know
it's a terrible grade on a spelling test
but a fantastic score on the pommel
horse but can we trust 43 as an approval
rating Trump said in February that any
negative polls are fake news but it's 43
negative well I'm told it's less than
half but what I'm really interested in
is trends and this number is technically
on the uptick who knows what it'll be
next week 45 95 it's a grower not a
shower and that's an argument I am
familiar with so 43 a good guy but where
else is numbers my big suited friends
say the stock market the stock market is
at an all-time high so I'm really proud
cuz a record in the history of our
country stock market tremendous gains
people that truly dislike your president
the heads of these companies are coming
up and hugging me and kissing me
when you're a star they let you do it
the stock market is up in fact the
Dowell recently set a new record when it
hit 22,000 but is that a number we can
trust now some whiny liberal economists
may tell you that this economic boom is
actually holdover growth from Obama's
policies like dodd-frank in the 2009
stimulus package they might even point
at census data that says real median
household income grew over the last two
years but I don't trust this who doesn't
lie to the census why should the
government know how many kids I have and
how many refrigerators I own and it's a
lot by the way to both questions so stop
asking I like cold things and little
people simple the point is 22,000 is a
good number for 45 not for 44 now you
can't hide from me number so let's put a
fresh one in the feed challenge me just
give me something Health and Human
Services Secretary Tom Price is in hot
water overtaking dozens of charter
flights on private jets at a cost of
over $400,000 to the taxpayers okay I
can do this now on the surface it seems
like Tom price a multi-millionaire
spending four hundred thousand dollars
in taxpayers money on personal travel I
mean that number sounds kind of like a a
bad guy but uh I got this follow me here
four hundred thousand four four is the
number of legs on a horse and horses
were popular in the 1830s eighteen
thirty is military time for six thirty
and six thirty is when the Sun Goes Down
and Sun is also a male child which is
who Tom Price was visiting and visiting
has eight letters and a son is half a
father eight divided in half is four and
what has four letters good Oh
so Tom price spending four hundred
thousand dollars of taxpayers money on
private transportation is a good number
close one
Oh finally the opposition premiered on
Monday and I had no doubt in my mind we
were the most-watched show of all time
but according to big Nielsen we were
eclipsed by young Sheldon whose numbers
were apparently larger than ours let me
be clear I don't get beaten by
nine-year-old nerds I haven't gotten
beaten up by a nine-year-old since I was
fifteen and once more when I was 21 but
there were two of them so technically I
got beat up by an 18 year old and that
hasn't happened since Tuesday so now
who's the math knowledge of Sheldon
[Music]